zurzeit arbeiten sehr viele menschen von
zu hause stichwort home office das ganze
läuft dann meist über videokonferenzen
weil ganz kann man auf meetings heran
doch nicht verzichten
aber das ganze bringt auch einige intime
einblicke bei kollegen die man sich
vielleicht auch hätte ersparen wollen
das ganz besonders zu sehen jetzt ein
pärchen in brasilien eine
video-konferenz person neue normalität
in corona zeigen doch während sieben der
teilnehmer alles mitarbeiter des
stadtrats von rio de janeiro angeregt
das thema wie fliegen wir studenten in
den kommunen während der pandemie
diskutieren zeigt sich der achter
teilnehmer er erregt als angeregt oder
sollten wir sagen er hat das meeting
verlassen und schon mal ein neues
begonnen eindeutige geht es nun wirklich
nicht der mann hat sex die kamera an
seinem computer fängt das wilde treiben
gnadenlos ein und alle teilnehmer der
video konferenz können ihm dabei zusehen
doch die kammer zu viel freizügigkeit
scheinbar gar nicht sie reden einfach
weiter über die arbeit einzig und allein
den mann mit mundschutz im fenster
rechts oben scheint die sache nicht kalt
zu lassen er holt verstärkung wie später
bekannt wurde musste man tatsächlich
externe kräfte zur hilfe holen damit der
anderweitig beschäftigte mitarbeiter aus
der konferenz genommen werden konnte
die dauerte übrigens noch vier stunden
und ging ohne weitere zwischenfälle
vonstatten